okay well yes and Jeremy and Jeremy
rank
s
[Music]
and Lifeline trying to kill a fly
[Laughter]
here we are fine again I understand what
I said it's Lifeline again I understand
it's funny what you said and I could
have said that oh I I bring a really
unique voice and I'm funny too dude so
don't try to be like
you know what I'm saying uh I actually
do know what you're saying there we go
so but whatever you know so look man we
have another episode of Lifeline we're
about to start another episode of
Lifeline it's all good and we're having
a good time
yeah we are having a good time having a
good time having a good time yeah and
I'll tell you this much we got a new
camera to cover uh the two producers and
that's great oh we did yeah it's right
there
um and uh it's great to have that
because you know every now and then they
want to pop some [__] and say some [__]
we got Anthony mic'd up finally uh and
it's good right yes sir great everything
is Anthony's back's feeling good today
that's good his back's feeling good
because his back wasn't feeling good for
a bit
um and uh it's weird to just say that
without context and that's fine but if
you say Anthony's back's feeling good
today it implies that his back hasn't
been feeling good right but then people
but when you say Anthony's back feeling
good today people think well wait hold
on what happened and now I have to
explain it you don't have to explain
right but that's okay well you do have
to explain it because it's a podcast
it's not a [__] movie made by like
you know what I mean Darren Aronofsky
and you just be like well the audience
will think what it thinks what if
darrenowsky Darren Aronofsky directed
this podcast wow dude it would be like
so it'll be all handheld yeah yeah all
close-ups yeah
and something biblical would happen yeah
then the movie would be bad oh the
religious one it's a hater it's a hater
somebody would drill something into
their head isn't that what happens in
pie ruined it wow so look um it's so old
yeah it's an old movie you know it's in
black and white it was in the 40s so
um look uh I was on my way here
and uh got in my car well gotta take a
sip that's great okay well this story is
terrible so far yeah but it really ramps
up uh I was getting out of the car I
walked by uh I was coming into the
building this guy was riding a bicycle
like one of these like with pretty wide
handlebars not like a Schwinn like one
that like is an older one that looked
like it could fall apart very easily
like the kind of bike that looks like
Cruiser hanging on the cliff yeah yeah
yeah like a fantasy yeah okay yeah I
mean it wasn't like he was [__] get
your motor on and down it was but it was
a cruiser like with a banana seat you
know what I'm talking about yeah the
seat that comes up and Scoops the your
back right
and he was riding on it past me I mean
the guy had to be in his 50s yeah had a
one of those FBI like police badges not
FBI but a police badge like he was in uh
what's that show with Michael Chiklis oh
the commish The Shield the shield on one
of these Cruisers with the banana on it
okay that that what was he and my
question is now what the hell do you
think he was doing a being a cop on his
day off letting people know flexing it
though that he's also a cop so don't
start anything or crazy person because
where was it downtown right outside it
was a crazy guy there's not even looking
like it though but but he was but why
did he have the badge the [__] wait I'm
I'm from Chicago why do you have the
badge uh because he's crazy so how do
you get the badge you can get a badge
made dude I was just listening to a
podcast episode about a guy who
pretended he was a cop all the time
and made like special made badges I want
to do that also maybe he stole a badge
from a cop right it is pretty crazy down
here I mean Donald Skid Row dude you can
get badges for anything right down the
street down on Skid Row
oh what do you mean down the street
there's uh I got like an army surplus
store
I got a guy I got the bike in the badger
the same place okay
I got a guy
um so so yeah so anyway uh that was what
happened and I was I wanted to get your
take on it well the tick is crazy person
okay because we're downtown downtown or
Hollywood if you ever have a question of
is that person really what they look
like they are or are they a crazy person
the answer is always a crazy person I
guess so yeah I guess you're probably
right the other day I was in Hollywood
and I saw a guy dressed like Barney the
dinosaur was it really Barney he was
running across the street and I thought
the same thing is that really Barney or
is that a crazy guy and I think it was a
crazy guy wow okay yeah well that's
great um are you gonna get more tattoos
yeah you're gonna get covered no I am
well did you oh you see my tattoos whoa
you got two but in the same place that's
pretty if I get another one I'm gonna go
to the same place why
let me see here oh because I feel like
it all right man I know you know you
don't have to be like that because I'm
the boss of me why I don't know I don't
like here's why okay I don't like
tattoos that are like
all over the body so at first you will
at the very at least at the very outset
I wanted my first two to be in the same
place you will you'll come around shut
up
you know what I mean dude how annoying
is it when someone's like you will yeah
that's I hate that more than anything I
know you do that's why I did it I hate
that that's why I did it okay well no I
didn't want it because I wanted to open
the door and talk about how much you
hate it okay Charlie Rose
um
dude
um all right so what's been going on
with you man I was on the road I was
home did you not want to talk about that
okay uh oh yeah how was the road it was
good I'm gonna be in New York coming up
here uh on the 18th I will be in Rhode
Island uh I will be in Kansas City
Missouri I will be in Tulsa I will be in
Minneapolis I will be in Austin I will
be in Midland Texas Milwaukee uh
chrisley.com and many more for tickets
chrisley.com and that's what's up Salt
Lake City Boise uh let's have a good
time dude don't push me remember don't
push me yeah Minneapolis no chinchinatti
no weird
no I'm not because I'm not racist no I'm
not my mistake though
um so yeah so I am uh it was good I was
in New Orleans I was in um different
places it doesn't really matter wow
bailed on yourself oh [__] hard it
doesn't matter I'll talk about in my
podcast Congress dude I've been doing
dealing with some pretty real stuff on
uh my one-on-one sessions oh really yeah
well that's cool people get pretty
serious with me on there and then I hang
up on them and block them forever no I
really welcome help them through their
issues and I'm a really good guy to
bounce stuff off yeah and I knew that
all along but the thing is now it's
proven because I've been doing this for
a while now I'm a therapist and people
really really love it and you're welcome
okay so go to matalia.com to get the
one-on-one of my sessions yeah and uh go
to watch lifeline.com if you have a
question click the link in the
description below and the new LL merch
Lifeline merch is uh lifetime merch.com
oh it pisses me off as you rent you ran
too fast through with my mathilea.com
thing no way because you you talked
about it so much you did it fast but you
talked about it so much so I say oh it's
mentally.com
no but that's it that's what you did the
heavy lifting and then I was like by the
way it's at mathlete.com I was like ring
ring through the neighborhood on a bike
and you just went
through it please badge on oh yeah with
the police badge all right
um so yeah I haven't seen you in how
long
has it been a while I guess
I think so last two two weeks ago last
week last week yeah we're getting
Construction done at the house and uh
Calvin you know how like you'll be
getting Construction done and it'll be
like you'll just be hanging out and then
all of a sudden you'll just hear like
yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you're just like are they
drilling or what's happening are they
putting boards up on the sides you know
are they scratched in the house and cal
every time he does a cow goes like this
I did it every time
so how often is he say that to 57 times
it's not happening that much oh it'll be
like every now and a bit you know and so
how did you shoot it how did you say it
he says I Toot It and then I laugh and
then he laughs what's up kids
finding out that something they did is
funny and then never stopping doing that
thing ever ever I'm still in that phase
yeah I know yeah I never stopped doing
that yeah but that's that's when you're
an adult it's annoying when you're a kid
it's really annoying no because at least
when you're an adult you know how to
like kind of do it operate it in a way
that's not super annoying but as a kid
it's just like like I was with Calvin
the other day and you weren't there I
wasn't and he was like
I made a joke about uh sneezing a
certain way you did I did okay and then
he immediately after I did it started
doing the exact same thing really and
making it so that it wasn't funny
anymore no it was still funny no it was
cute it wasn't funny anymore though uh
yes it was oh okay I'll argue with you
on that okay what was the thing I made
him laugh by saying I sneezed like this
oh okay and then he laughed really hard
and he said I go like this
snake
pumpkin
watermelon and it was just like that's
really funny yeah that would keep being
funny no matter how many times wow okay
um
what you're biased there really is lost
your mind how weird is it what about the
fact that you used to sing the Lucky Dog
song yeah when I was a kid I bet that
was too um like a dog I'm a lucky dog I
didn't know everyone was listening to me
I go I'm a lucky dog and then I stopped
and everyone clapped to the dining table
felt shame all good no but then
but then you sang it all the time to
make people laugh okay I think I
probably did it that was one of the last
times I did it wow I'm being honest you
retired it at that point yeah everyone
was making was was laughing with
clapping on me they thought it was cute
and I was like ah [__] I really actually
thought it was rocking and they think
I'm cute this is actually crappy made me
feel shame set me up further in my life
so now I do it but it's all good though
how old were you when I did that yes
well we moved to LA when I was 12 so
before that
I don't know not at all I don't know how
long before you know what I mean I mean
because obviously you were before 12. I
have no idea though okay
um so anyway dude
you know we could get into some stuff
here you want to get into some stuff
okay well don't be shitty about it I
mean yeah duh
all right whoa I'm a huge fan of the
podcast it's the best podcast out there
in my opinion wow I'm an animator and
graphic designer and I'm starting to
worry about AI developing at a rapid
Pace I'm not sure if it's a threat or an
ally to designers in the industry I've
already lost clients should I be worried
what are your thoughts on AI such as
chat GPT and mid-journey affecting the
creative field and anyways here are your
images made with mid-journey
here is Matt on an airplane after
terrifying all of the passengers with
his Xanax freak out whoa and here is
Chris looking dope as [__] look what it
says why it says Phil philan on his
shirt thanks guys wow that was Max
Headroom that's my favorite guy because
he involved me and it made him look and
an image of me was in it okay it's my
favorite one okay you know so I was just
thinking about this actually I I think
we're all thinking about this a lot
lately because everyone's scared because
everyone knows it's happening it's bad
it's coming for a truck everyone from
truck drivers to you're done
screenwriters screen everybody in
between yeah designers oh absolutely
yeah you should be worried without a new
question you should be worried yep uh
you should already be thinking about
ways that you can be a doctor no doctors
are way too yeah I know are you kidding
me doctors are going to be the first
ones that are out I know imagine going
to medical school for nine years and
then at the very end they're just like
no we don't need proctologists we don't
get this robot that goes inside your ass
and you don't even feel it and it cures
everything you ever had in your ass
oh
disgust
disgust so painful so painful
so so painful yeah but it feels
strangely good because it's the robot I
don't know how to do it I think
everybody is going to be at the very
least like slightly
touched by the AI boom but it's not
gonna happen like right away you look
like you're in your 30s you're probably
fine I don't know it happens really bad
it does but like the full takeover I
think will take a while
what's gonna happen is it's gonna start
being laws that protect workers in all
fields
and
because they're trying to get away no
and that's okay what
go ahead hello no help no help
no fixed oh my God why are they trying
to get away because it hurts but the
robot knows why would they do it if it
hurts then it's it's yeah is that the AI
does it in a way that doesn't hurt they
have to take the cancer anyway okay
anyway uh relax the government is gonna
at least in places like America gonna
come up with laws that prohibit the AI
to that take away certain jobs but
in places like China and Russia they're
not going to prohibit that [__] so in
China they're going to have the greatest
AI [__] ever and no one will have jobs
there anymore but the government will
give a [__] here they're going to try to
prolong it as long as possible but it
still won't matter
oh
in China
oh no oh no no relax
missed no no no no no oh
relax catch these Tunes we built this
city we built this city on rock and roll
the most oh it's a good song We Built
This City
oh
okay you good yeah okay um and then so
but that'll be China that's the most
Chinese song to play too no it's not it
is
all right all right all right cool uh
but yeah I want to do that but so bad
you kept talking dude everyone is
screwed with AI I know it's just
everyone is messed up and it's not gonna
be good for anybody what do you think
the last job will be that uh
is okay fine
like wait what do you mean at the last
job that AI could possibly take over
because it's such a human
I mean I think I think actually athletes
because no one cares
if they're non-human can win because
they know it can right right right so
anything athletic and most competition
things no one is going to want to attend
or care if as something non-humans doing
it right so Sports
but that's I mean that's such a limited
I know so few people are good enough at
sports to play them maybe art you know
like painting ah see yeah I think that
but I guarantee you something in five
six years is going to change our minds
about it yeah yeah yeah I totally agree
they're gonna like understand
abstraction or something you know what I
mean which is the thing that's missing
yeah you know the human element is
always like the creative part but this
chat GPT stuff it's like it writes
better on the spot stories than I mean
we can yeah and they used to have agents
like cover
like Junior agents cover what the
scripts are about and now you can just
have Chad gbd do that yes and they write
better log lines than you and they do it
in a [__] second yes so it's crazy
dude but but Proctologist for sure is
gone yeah surgeons are maybe not doctors
who are like GPS yeah prognosticators or
whatever you call them yeah but or
diagnosticians you know what I'm saying
yeah okay cool because I don't but not
diagnosticians because that will be able
to they'll put little bugs in your thing
and they'll go
and I'll be like I know what it is for
some stuff but sometimes there's like a
like a suite of symptoms that only a
human would be able to know because it's
like I don't think so okay well I don't
think you're right a little bit but
think about it for a little bit okay
oh I'm right you didn't think about it
no I mean you might be right but I'm
saying that's
the ones who diagnose are going to be
they're the longest The Virgins are out
yeah because the doctor will be like the
doctor bot will be like
oh wait it is has actually nothing to do
with the anus
my bad what the heck
now oh no that's okay no lawsuit please
when I went in for surgery for my
sinuses the drip of the drugs took like
too long oh no no it was yes oh no
because you was feeling nice but like
there was the single best feeling I've
ever had was the slow drip of
because it's the best feeling I have and
I'll never have a better feeling oh no
what was it that they were giving you
they were giving you yeah yeah I
actually don't know the doctor would
come along with with some powder he's
like here you go and just you're like
what was that oh my god oh dude
no they were playing flat Fat Bottom
Girls by Queen really yeah for real oh
wow and then one of the doctors was
singing and they were like hey like when
I came in it was like I was like whoa
everybody's so happy I didn't feel so
good because of the drug what did it
feel like it felt like I weighed nothing
it felt like nothing in the world could
possibly matter oh wow I felt so just
happy was it did you for it truly
euphoric wow did it feel better than
Bustin I mean by so much what that isn't
common it felt because it was way more
all encompassing oh it wasn't just like
us uh located anywhere it was every it
was everything everywhere about
everything it's about this and coming so
I'm coming day and night I mean it's
terrific right
so yeah that's that's me so yeah you're
worried you're [__] dude everyone's
[__] yeah designers totally screwed uh
I mean he said he's already losing
clients yeah nobody's not going to be
touched by this you should be very
scared yeah uh
that's it even stand-up comedy the funny
bot in on uh live
um South Park have you ever seen the
funny box no no it's so funny dude they
do Comedy Awards and Germans come in
last place and they're like we are funny
and then they make a funny bot that's
great and then the funny bot does a joke
and the German guy has like a gun and
he's like yeah so who's funny now like
oh wow that's cool it's really funny
South Park is the funniest show I know
it's funny it's very funny okay let's do
it this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp uh when I go to therapy and
I'm grounded it really it therapy really
helps me be grounded and it helps me
feel like my best self right
um so I need to be in therapy uh it's
necessary for me uh and when you're at
your best which is when I'm at my best I
can do great things uh but sometimes
look life gets me down life can get you
down and you may feel overwhelmed or
like you're showing up uh in a way that
you uh don't want to or you're not
showing up in the way that you do want
to working with the therapist can really
help you get closer to the better
version of you uh when you feel
empowered you're more prepared to take
on everything life throws at you if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is the it is such a great
option it's super convenient it's
flexible it's affordable and best of all
it's entirely online you don't have to
go somewhere all you got to do is just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
matched with a licensed therapist uh and
switch therapists anytime you want with
no extra charge it's just the easiest
way to do it and in these times too with
everything on Zoom it's just it's really
beneficial and it's great if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
Lifeline today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash lifeline
one
Chris Marco what's up guys I've got a
question about being an audience member
at a stand-up show that is not going
well is it nice to give a comedian pity
laughs or is it better feedback to not
laugh at all and let them know that
they're bombing good question let me
know what you think yeah either leave or
don't laugh unless you want to laugh
jeez really yeah why I would think the
opposite give him a little bit of a
chocolate yeah
people always tell me at comedy shows
they feel bad if no one's laughing right
then if that's true though why is no one
laughing
you see what I'm saying well if
everybody feels bad that someone's
bombing then why is no one courtesy
laughing because some people in those
situations it's pretty rare that people
are laughing just to be nice I don't
know that's just like an open mic you
know right yeah uh I mean you could tell
what those kinds of laughs are and
they're awful and when I hear them which
is never but you know they're the worst
you hear other for other people and it's
like oh this is terrible I'd rather
though just not laughing at all you need
to be good you need to be good you're
not going to get good there needs to be
stand up is hard because it's [__]
hard you can't do it and and Coast this
is like you're gonna you're gonna do and
get these pity laughs from friends this
is why a lot of these [__] people get
like nowadays Netflix specials and [__]
because they're just like you know they
fit a bill or some [__] and it's like
and they're not actually funny yeah it
happens all the time and uh that's true
yeah I mean there's a different they
call it clapter you know where people
are just like
it's like they're more just like
applauding the person doing it I've
never heard that yeah it's a funny term
but it's just like dude laugh
[__] yeah like I don't give a
[__] about the the the the the the I
mean I care about the points you're
making but secondary to being funny dude
yeah you know it's like you're not Dave
Chappelle up there like you already did
everything and now you can talk about
whatever you want yeah right yeah
[__] don't know who you are
yeah be funny wow but but seriously like
these people are out there and it's like
oh like dude stand Up's hard as [__] bro
you need it to be hard otherwise people
won't be good
it's not it's not something that's by
the numbers right like there's not a
definitive oh you're good or not it's
like you just have to be utterly
hilarious I guess AI would be one of the
last things that maybe yeah comedy would
be one of the last things that AI maybe
but it's like dude I don't know I
obviously feel a certain way about this
but like
dude there's like you can get a fan base
by being okay but like you can't you
can't like be in the middle of a lineup
and be okay you suck like you need to go
and you need to make [__] laugh
and some people just go up and they're
fine and those people are forgotten
about in a room of 300 yes like you like
when you go to the Laugh Factory when
you go to these clubs like these most of
the time like on a week on a weekend you
get these people who can kill some are
famous some are not famous but they kill
and every now and then there's a weak
link because of somebody because of this
and that because it's a friend of a
person and they [__] utterly blow
they utterly blow and everyone in the
audience is like this
does it make people leave
but sometimes so you're saying the
audience does it right then they don't
laugh or anything they shouldn't but
you're saying they don't sometimes yeah
okay yes yes yes they don't they don't I
mean sometimes they're like okay well
this is the Laugh Factory and like
hahaha but like you go to some of these
[__] shows like at The Comedy Store
late at night like the bills on this
[__] they're just [__] terrible
they're terrible and you know I get it
like they Coast off the brand and that's
fine but you know if dude if I'm on a
show and they there are terrible
comedians it [__] sucks for me I want
people to think I want some people to
think I was the best I want some people
to think other person's the best I dude
I don't want to be the best all the time
it [__] sucks some some of these some
of these comedians go on I'm going on
right now but some of these comedians
take comedians who aren't funny to open
for them because they don't want to work
hard yeah yeah you suck bro you suck you
I bring people who kill Mike linoche
Denny love Lulu Gonzalez these people
kill like
Adam Ray he kills dude you can't go on
the road and bring you you will start to
suck you will it will catch up to you
that's why you see you know people in
the in in the comedy club like old old
timers if they come in the comedy club
and they haven't been working the clubs
they [__] suck now yeah but if they
do it all the time and they're
Old-Timers then they kill because they
know what it's like to be in a comedy
club and they know what it's like to
[__] to take that that temperature of
the comedy club you want me to go no I
don't know I just [__] I went off on
it but the guy asked a question that I'm
obviously passionate about dude I'm so
tired of [__] terrible comedians man
I'm so tired of them I don't even like
watching good comedians so I feel you on
that for sure yeah I mean when you you
know it's like there are guys that I
wouldn't go see but I'm like I get what
he's doing and that's great he has a fan
base and he's killing and yeah yeah like
you can't argue if someone's good or not
yeah
if they're killing they're killing yeah
yeah yeah yeah they got their fan base
yeah so you know
okay
so so next one before Chris has a
conniption fit yeah also the same guy
all right what's up Matt what's up Chris
uh Chris I've been a true baby since uh
before there was a term for it nice uh I
saw you on uh Fargo North Dakota a
handful of years back and it was a great
show I remember that well uh but I'm
looking for a little bit of advice uh in
a situation that I'm in uh in regards to
my relationship uh I've been dating my
boyfriend for close to three years now
uh we spend most of our nights together
we're not we don't live together
um he'll mostly come over to my place
and stay and I'll sometimes go over to
his place
um but recently there's two sisters that
he lives with got two cats uh and
they're pissing everywhere or something
or either it's litter box just smells
like piss so now the whole house smells
like piss uh and I rarely went there
already uh and now that the house smells
like piss I have like very little desire
to go there yeah
um and it's starting to put a little bit
of tension in our relationship that I
won't go uh I'm just kind of wondering
what you guys would do what advice you
would give me appreciate it love you
both peace out thanks bro so three um
first I'm gonna say three years is so
long to not live together
yeah I don't know just move have him
move in with you depends what they want
you know like a young gay guy three
years is a long time though yeah to not
to to be dating and not have started
living together but guys but the other
thing I was gonna say they're both guys
right cat piss smell yeah it's the worst
yeah
dude I used to date a girl who I thought
at the beginning of our relationship for
a long time smelled amazing in the last
few months something happened something
happened where she started smelling like
cat piss and I just was I I it didn't
matter how I felt about her it it was
all messed up she smelled like catfish
now so I was just like Angry all the
time because smells like really upset
you they get under your skin without you
even realizing it sometimes then you
think you smell it even when you double
eat [__] it's just like and then it
would be like even after she would leave
the room it would like she'd leave
anyway my point is cat piss is the worst
smell it ruins love
okay it ruins love the smell of cat piss
ruins love so if you love this guy make
him leave that place if you don't want
to move in with you he has to move into
somewhere else but you cannot coexist in
a romantic relationship when cat pisses
in the air the end but the Paul Simon
song I think
um I think you know again
um and the man walk down the street in
front of campus and so uh I don't know I
think that um yeah I I I I I don't think
it's that weird to be a young gay guy
with another young gay guy and not move
in well he's not for 19. he's in his 20s
okay but I just feel like but that's a
young gay guy dude gay guys are young
till they're like 55 you know all right
but three years and [__] my point can I
fin let me finish my point is that guys
don't give a [__] about that a lot of
the time it's always women that are like
what are we you know and no guys [__]
I mean maybe there's some guys doing it
but like the guy seems chill as [__] if
you he's with another dude that's
like-minded they're probably like yo man
this is cool but then the cap has gone
involved so it's like okay yeah no I
understand but doesn't he hang out that
guy's place a lot anyway and he already
didn't go over there so you guys should
either have him move in and or say yo I
can't come over because the cap is
that's it the campus is terrible
honestly people shouldn't even have cats
he should say move in because your place
smells like campus and I can't love
under these conditions
your place smells like move-in because
your place smells like cat piss and also
side note I love you so move in only I
only love you when we're not smelling
cat piss yeah it's it's that's a rough
that's a rough situation but the guy's
got to know what I don't understand is
people have cats and then they have this
smell
not if they take care of the cat I've
been I've been to people who've been to
people's homes who own cats it I don't
smell the catfish at all because they
change over the litter box they don't
they know what they're doing with their
cat yeah the sisters obviously don't
know what they're doing with the cats
yeah yeah yeah okay so anyway
you can't this this is it okay cat piss
kills love okay
so get out of there okay for good cat
you're in kills love yeah all right
from cat you're in with love
here we go
so so much such a low shot or high shot
whatever Headroom okay so Matt big fan
from Australia that you are looking pimp
and Pimpin today
Chris you look fat my problem is that my
friend is having a karaoke party for her
30th
um I'm a professional singer and I don't
want to be that wanker that gets up and
tries to do really well at karaoke
um but I also am not the type of person
who can properly get up and do like a
funny big entertaining over the top show
so I don't really know what to do
my thoughts are to do a duet that's
probably my best way about it or to just
get very drunk but I would love your
advice thanks guys love the show I
actually think that you should only do
karaoke if you can kill it I was just
gonna say go up there and absolutely
Slaughter annihilate and kill and make
everyone who else who tries to feel dumb
do a hard song too yeah there's so many
things I've been killed and do a song
that nobody else can see karaoke to me
is not fun it's not funny I think that
you should go up and absolutely destroy
what was that noise
are they gonna hear that well they're
gonna hear that
the [__] karaoke sucks it's it's uh
unless you're good you're good kill it
don't be funny about it here's the worst
thing the person who thinks it's funny
to do a rap song Like A white guy that
gets something that's getting jiggy with
it and you think there's so many white
guys because you think I can't sing so
[__] it and then you do it by the time
you're in the middle of like the fourth
bar you're like it's so [__] hard so
true so so I don't think karaoke is a
good thing unless you can [__] I
actually like karaoke uh even when
people are bad if it's a person I like
if I'm with a tight crew that I'm good
friends with karaoke is kind of always
fun to me but it's never like a thing I
want to go do yeah karaoke is a thing I
have fun when like we're not at
someone's house and they have a karaoke
thing wow and it's all of us hanging out
you want to know each other yeah wow
yeah I mean I'm a great singer well
you're a bad singer but no I sing um
I sing uh this is a song called plush
I mean
American Psycho what is that it's plush
by Stone Temple Pilots what is this
before the acoustic version he says this
is a song called the plush
okay well yes and Jeremy and Jeremy
oh [__] it all right let's go this
around wow not even how it goes at all
the the glycerin song so wait what was
the advice for her go and kill it
absolutely this is your [__] dude if it
was a comedy night I'm not gonna go up
and do bad comedy
yeah yeah dude I'm gonna go up and ding
ding
douche and the [__] body parts all
over the room I think we need to give
her um some song uh choices yeah
glycerin
uh you want to kill it
yeah I will always
[Applause]
do and she feels it that note is
terrible that note was so flat it was
unbelievable where are we going until
tomorrow
who sings that
who sings it who where she smell low
what is that song
I gotta tell you dude Stone Temple
Pilots like I said Stone Temple Pilots
would hear that and go like this wow I
never heard something like that so badly
one time I when I used to tweet and I
don't tweet anymore because I don't I
really did touch Twitter like this years
I haven't tweeted yeah uh I tweeted that
I was in the Spin Doctors yeah and he
and and the guy in the Spin Doctors
replied yeah who doesn't follow me right
and I didn't tag them and he said funny
I don't remember that I slammed me so I
don't know hard dude like wow dude I was
just having fun you know yeah funny I
don't remember that I that um yeah it I
had that was the worst when you were
singing that that was the worst I've
ever felt
Pandora baby
it's got no way this really is the best
podcast there is huh yeah there it is
was in the that's a different one oh
I've done it before you've done it
before wow oh wait maybe that was I mean
so many spin doctor tweets
that's it where's the guy where's the
guy in it he probably deleted it he was
upset
there are that many responses
wow oh he doesn't he didn't even say
funny he just said don't remember that
wow wow hey what's his name what's his
name go back to it
Chris Barron hey Chris Barron come and
get me bro well it was years ago his
brother no no no no no I know it's been
festering as much for you as it has been
for me you might be dead come and get me
we're gonna send you my address you meet
me outside ring the doorbell
and be prepared he's a good looking dude
yeah he's good he's good looking he's
good he's good he's handsome he's a good
guy he's in a good band pin doctors what
even is that it's uh a little Miss can't
be wrong remember that oh wow okay
all right all right who's the next one
Chris Matt Matt and Chris what is
happening uh got a question for you all
want some advice on
how do you tell somebody that they're
saying a word wrong or a name wrong or a
city wrong without
um being sounding like sadik it is very
thick
great example is Chris always says
Sugarland Texas when talking about Sugar
Land Sugar Land Texas where you're going
this weekend
um well you just did it so yeah question
is how do you sound like a total
[__] to somebody while trying
Spider-Man correct them on the way they
say it Batman uh anyways I'm excited to
hear what y'all gotta say
wait hold on let me just get this out of
the way Sugarland
is not weird to call it that way Sugar
Land like it's a [__] made-up fairy
tale place like it's the land of sugar
[__] off Sugarland is you know how many
how do you say the word land land and
how do you say the word Sugar Sugar so
it should go Sugar Land but you're
acting like that's how the English
language always works but it doesn't
always work like that but he's like from
there words change when they go into the
same thing okay sure sure sure but
you're making it up no no he's saying
with knowledge I'm assuming priority I'm
sure of the way he's in Texas obviously
he's got a Texas hat on
Sugar Land okay but it isn't that's all
he's saying that's fine there are
certain words that I change because I
want to and it's better all right well
anyway okay the way to do that for
people I honestly often don't do that
even though I'm constantly catching
obviously I mean everybody catches
everybody saying oh I do it all this
word wrong uh but I and the reason I
don't correct them is because honestly
they're here's why there is no good way
first of all second of all it doesn't
matter we're all gonna die yeah you know
oh we're all gonna die that person's
gonna die stylist everyone else in the
world is going to die everyone who lived
before is already dead
is gonna die okay so it's just like why
would I correct you uh and say that
you're saying uh my hometown wrong maybe
you know maybe not everyone dies you
don't know that not everyone has died
yet yeah in in the history there's still
people alive
um but um yeah I go like this
oh man you're saying it this way dude
but it's not that it's this right so
what the [__] are we gonna do dude
that's not dick it's funny
because it is so dick but come at it
with some sort of you know brevity or a
sense of humor if you can't do that then
just don't do it levity not brevity both
means brevity just means short oh yeah
right
brevity means short brevity means keep
it like brevity is myself
uh it doesn't Okay levity I know what
levity means but I think everybody also
meant the same thing but it means short
you're right I mix it up there at least
I'm not saying providing well which
because then you'd be like oh [__]
you're saying it wrong brevity
um
all right all right yeah dude I think
that that's like you have to come at it
with some sort of humor because
people don't think you're a dick no
matter what so you got to come out of it
or
or you [__] or you [__] it up yeah or
or you just let them go yeah let them go
okay but nobody if it's your name it's
annoying of course no wait yeah that's
right right if it's your name right it's
not dick at all to be like and the but
the way to do it is probably something
like look I know like everybody always
does this but it's actually Delia or
whatever right I had a I had a um
oh the flight attendant she says uh is
it the Ilya and I said Delia and she
said great hello Mr Delia
that happens a lot I'm like would you
like that's you in the middle oh yeah
they can't quite get to that there's a
lot to you yeah I haven't noticed I mean
I'm not sure or or Delia and I'll
correctly say it's actually Delia and
they'll just like say something in
between what the wrong thing they said
and the right thing that I said yeah
okay Mr Delia and I said Delia but
whatever anyway so yeah yeah and so
everybody was happy yeah I wasn't she
[__] up all right cool next one
Chris I've been a fan since
encourageable I saw you in Dallas I
think it's your best work yet thank you
Chris thank you so there's this guy I
work with that smells so oh
strongly of Dove soap I can smoke when
he's coming from across the world I
can't beat up soap like 70 feet away
what's wrong with that that's no [__]
joke I'm just saying all right I clocked
it like it's this guy's Saint Bernard an
unbelievable
amount of how does that smell like it
smells carrying Dove soaps I am a
[__] Dove soap bar it smells like
it's like right before here what pretty
much at all times we work in the same
department so we're by each other all
day
I don't understand how you can pull that
off and we're not that tight so it's not
like I can like
tell them what's up so
what do you guys think I know exactly
what to do okay well I know exactly what
say
I know we don't know which this is gonna
sound weird like be colloquial and like
dude about it when you approach him and
just be like I just have to know
how
how do you possibly smell so good all
the time even if you don't think that's
good right yeah say you smell like Dove
soap from so far away I can smell you
coming and I know like just no joke okay
no no nothing I just need to know how
you smell like that all the time so
let's play this out he wants him to
obviously stop smelling like that soap
so much
so let's play this out but he's not
gonna you can't you you can't make a
stranger stop smelling a certain way you
can only find out how it goes you can if
you say what's going on oh and I'm not
saying say this because it'll be weird
but like if you find out what he's doing
to get to that smell then you can
possibly shift what he does to make it
so because it's offensive dude it also
I'm gonna go out of limb here it's not
Dove soap I'm gonna do okay how how much
could you wash how how how bad could
Dove soap smells amazing but but if a
smell is too strong all the time it's
annoying I'll agree with this guy even
if it's amazing stuff soap it's like one
of the best smells in the world that's
why I'm saying I don't think it's the
soap this guy's watching so much and and
what is it you'd have to bring dub soaps
around and be like this he has been
through all of these thoughts he's ahead
of us he understands the unlikelihood of
it okay it's just still true though so
it's Dove soap let's just go with it
what do we know we don't go with that I
can't get behind that I love this dude
and thank you so much for saying this is
my best workout in Dallas but
that smells like Dove soap well that
clone doesn't exist because all cologne
smells like shish kebab okay well it
doesn't smell like shish kebab you know
but like uh just [__] peppers and
chickens
a mush is a mushroom too yeah
um onions so is it like onions Peppers
mushrooms and chicken uh and wood dude
you can't it's not done so I push back
on that that's making me so mad
[__] that it doesn't even matter okay
so let me ask you a question I go I take
a shower I you've used up Dove soap all
over my body yeah then I go to then I go
to where you are you're gonna be able to
smell that Dove soap no okay I go I take
a shower for five hours I not only wash
all of the five hours I also eat some of
the Dove soap put it in my [__] I've
got two bars under my [__]
um armpits and I'm doing like this for
five hours okay yeah then I go to where
you are yeah you smell that probably
probably do something
right I agree it's not what he's doing
but like his laundry it's got to be it's
got to be here you go yeah it says
laundry so it's not Dove so but it
smells like Dove soap he didn't say it
is he said okay he thinks his stuff's
soap it doesn't matter uh Mr Miyagi
what's happening
um there's a fly uh okay for those
visiting he's clapping at nothing okay
so then say well I was trying to kill
the fly okay but so then so then say hey
what is it that smells so strong
you gotta stop no don't say you gotta
stop first ask like you're curious
because you want to know because
maybe you maybe you want to do the same
thing but the way you're doing it is not
good because if you do it in any sort of
you smell so good then you can't be like
don't do that because you guys I thought
it was good you gotta come out because
then you can say then they can say what
it is you could say okay well it smells
so good it gives me a [__] headache
please stop
um I have a golf coach that he also
smells so good like I can smell him from
10 feet away right and I think it's his
laundry and I've wanted to it doesn't
bother me but I've wanted to
like somehow in a funny way bring it up
to him like how do you smell so good and
I am really comfortable with him and I
still haven't done it then ask him what
I suggested but here's my thing about
this guy this caller bring up in a funny
way go like this for [__] sake why do
you smell so good
why does it bother him
is a magical smell it would bother me if
I had to smell something all of the time
it would bother me no because you just
gonna you wouldn't even notice that you
smell it anymore yeah no yeah it would
bother me I don't like good smells for
longer than a few whiffs okay man I'm
telling you man why does it I don't okay
okay I am in control if you want to know
what it is do what I said if you wanted
to stop I don't know what it is that's
what I said but you're saying it oh God
it's also good he doesn't
well maybe he thinks he smells so good
but I don't know dude I'm just saying
don't do it in a way to where to wear
you know it emboldens him yeah exactly
exactly all right next one all right
so much I love you guys I love the
podcast really appreciate it thank you I
have a question about rekindling a
relationship with something that I once
knew very deeply but don't anymore for
me that's exercise I have been active my
entire life I played division one soccer
in college and then life happened and I
had to take a break to focus on other
things
I'm now 30 years old sitting outside of
the gym currently and [__] [__] sucks
yeah I don't want to do it I'm bad at it
the pregnant lady is lifting more than
me and it's really frustrating and
discouraging
I'm looking for advices on how to
approach the situation with Grace not
compare myself to who I used to be Chris
did you have a similar experience
getting back into comedy
um I'd love to hear your guys's opinions
uh thank you so much okay bye it takes a
while to fall in love with something
again after you stop and you get used to
life
um you got set in your ways and it's all
about now the neural Pathways that you
set right uh you also worked out a lot
when you didn't want to if you were a
[__] athlete right so now you're
doing it to keep fit and you know
hopefully you know it's good for your
health but yeah dude um but it's not
about high performance it's not about
right exactly so don't compare yourself
to back then because you're not going to
be that because most for the most part
you just don't want to and that's okay
uh so go in and just I think go in and
don't be like hey uh
I'm gonna go to the gym and kill it go
to the gym just to go to the gym just
move around you're doing it by the time
you're you're you're you know develop
the Habit is what I'm saying develop the
habit of going right because I didn't
want to go on stage for like months when
I came back and I just kept doing it for
me it was because of Calvin I needed to
prove to him I could do it
um but you know find that reason why you
would need to go to the gym now it's not
your career right now it's not your you
know but you want to go because you want
to stay healthy and I think that that's
great I think everybody should work out
um yeah I think it's about developing
the habit and also going just just give
yours give yourself the
um leeway to just go and keep your body
moving right you don't have to [__]
kill it you can't under any circumstance
much like not just going to the gym and
comparing your body to what it once was
you can't compare you now to a previous
version of you because it's not
applicable not just because you used to
actually play a sport and now you don't
but because you were a completely
different person back then with
completely different goals and
completely different ideas about life
than you are now so think about what you
were then and why why can't I be like I
was then it's only going to make it even
harder to start working out again and
liking it again you might not like it it
might be a chore but all you have to do
is make sure you go to the gym it's like
as a writer I've had severe writer's
block but as long as I sit down and make
my fingers go on the keys it I will end
up writing something it might be bad but
it will be something whereas if I
compare myself to a state of you know
when I was like on fire feeling good
about what I was writing when I'm
currently in a writer's block mode I
will think like well I can't do this
anymore I suck this isn't coming and
then I won't you know the sun will be
coming down I won't have written a word
so you just got to stop comparing
yourself to a previous version of
yourself because not because it's so bad
for you you got to block it out but
because it is literally not applicable
you're a different person with different
ideas your brain's completely different
chemically it's proven it's just true
you are not the same person so don't
even bother comparing yeah I think that
uh that's right and uh also you were
like soccer is the [__] hardest you
just never stop running
you ever see me play soccer though it
wasn't that hard for me yeah no it was
it was no when did you play soccer last
you were 12 no I was like 12 yeah AYSO I
played it I did a bicycle kick scored
one goal it was on the wrong goal was on
our goal and that's it then that's the
truth oh yeah
dude I'll never forget that there's a
second is that the second episode
we will mentioned him last time yeah
because we're talking about Isis Morgan
nozaki oh [__] were we uh
he was a goalie with the big ass gloves
and [__] does anyone buy them yeah oh
yeah yeah he scored and I was like oh
sorry dude I don't know I saw bicycle
kick earlier on TV I saw an opportunity
and I just went for it yeah dude you hit
my shin you know it didn't hit my foot
but it went in I mean the wrong hour ago
yeah yeah but soccer is crazy huh I I
wish I had [__] God I wish I could do
something like that play soccer you know
like I'm so bad at running yeah we both
have that we're not good Runners yeah
yeah dude I saw a movie uh on the plane
or no actually it was when I was getting
my tattoo so different
well so different the reason why I got
confused is because it was I knew the
only reason why I watched the movie was
because of what I was doing not because
I wanted to go see the movie hit based
okay no it's not dude it's really not
okay hit based okay that is but um it
was called No Escape it was the Owen
Wilson and that Lake belgaum you know
like that's called No No Escape is the
Ray Liotta movie oh what's the movie
with Lake Bell and Owen Wilson Oh I know
that really bad movie
what's it called Nobody's looking it up
I'm pissed
um is Lake Belling that Lake Bell and
Owen Wilson it's really it's an action
movie right yeah it's really fun I saw
some of that it was so the dodo brothers
made that okay what's that uh they're
just no Escape brother filming oh it is
not an escape yeah
so the thing about that movie is Owen
Wilson is just a regular guy and when he
runs it's like your dad is running okay
and this movie is sad and I can't watch
movies like this anymore now that I have
a kid that's not sad it's an action
movie dude it's sad because they take
the kid and then they run with the kids
it's like a shitty action movie of
course he gets his kid at the end I feel
a certain type of way about it oh okay
well
um don't watch that movie in general
watch the original No Escape which is
with Ray Liotta and it's dope wait a
minute hold on go up that has how many
views on the trailer
right there in the middle
if I have a million six million six
million people watched a trailer to No
Escape that's crazy to me but it's
Pierce brosn and Owen Wilson dude what's
the big deal well almost I mean you know
he's in some good [__] he's a big star
yeah I guess so
but anyway the
I will yeah Pierce is in that dude I saw
some of that that's right but my point
is that it's hard
to
like when you're not an athlete and you
run this is the thing about that they
they cut around it and [__] like in
other with other guys but like some
people are good at running like Tom
Cruise is fantastic at running he's a
great careers running yeah but like um
confirm his best running is in The Firm
yeah well I guess he used to run track
or something that's what my mom says so
who knows if it's true but
um if Mom said it she said Houston on
track but also he's short yeah
everyone's height if someone's not six
feet they're short as hell yeah but if
they're over six feet they're tall
she'll say like Liam Neeson I have such
a crush on him he's so tall oh wow
that's funny yeah
um
height is like tits for a girl for when
it comes to
is it no okay all right no because girls
would do it doesn't matter yeah exactly
don't care yeah exactly as long as
you're cool and you are comfortable you
make them feel good yeah make them feel
good you got to make them feel good but
not too good right nope good good only
good good yeah but not but leave a
little mystery right now open the door
mystery not the other way I mean yeah
you don't want to over explain
everything you do that's why I'm opening
the door Focus I like you open the door
for them as they leave and then when
you're getting out from the restaurant
don't open the door for them so they'll
be like huh do you like me more before
the dinner did I [__] up no no that's
too close to negging
both times but both times you say you
don't know why I did this
[Laughter]
or they you open the door they get in
and then you close the door uh
just like that huh okay
that would make him feel really like
what the [__] yeah but see that's too
close to negative okay I think you you
open the door for them they go through
the door and then you know you either
sit down at the table at the restaurant
or get in the car together and you say
so do you have any ideas about why I did
that um
so I opened the door for you when you
got out of the car and when we got to
the restaurant I did that do you know
why I did that
no would you like to know I'm not
telling you yeah anybody's guess yeah
that is actually really cool that would
be very cool to do yeah I would do that
okay well I'm gonna do that to Kristen
you're welcome
um so yeah well I don't know okay we did
that one yeah Okay cool so then I guess
we're done no yeah we started the clock
a little late so we should just be done
did we really start the clock like a
couple minutes
oh
you added time to it so it's less than
53. let's feed um
all right we can be done let's speed up
we gotta do another episode let's meet
that's a bad song don't do that let's
listen guys
I will be in New York come see me
chrisley.com I will be in Kansas City I
will be in Rhode Island I will be in um
oh Kansas City Cincinnati Kansas City
here we come Springfield Tulsa Midland
Texas Austin Milwaukee Minneapolis
Columbus
Salt Lake City
good keep going uh mattelia.com for the
one-on-one sessions come to me with your
deep dark secrets or feelings about
yourself or everyday troubles doesn't
matter book me private advice sessions
Tuesdays and Thursdays uh I'll love you
if you book them I hate you if you don't
and uh if you have a question uh for us
on this show click the link in the
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com and of course get your fine
fantasy Lifeline merch at
lifelinemerch.com yeah we have a good
time like And subscribe babies yeah like
And subscribe to the channel super good
yep super good yay
[Music]